c'est une joie c'est un vrai bonheur de
m'exprimer aujourd'hui devant vous pour
vous dire que grâce à tout l'union de la
droite
grâce à tout ce qu'on fait les
sympathisants les adhérents les gens des
bouches-du-rhône et je salue tous les
militants des bouches du rhône qui sont
venus en masse aujourd'hui pour ce
premier congrès des républicains que
nous avons en famille fin à soixante et
dix ans de socialo héridis mme
communiste au sein des bouches du rhône
c'est historique c'est une fin
d'histoire c'est la provence qui s'est
soulevée elle s'est soulevée par ce que
l avais envie de dire à ses stops et
nous avons mis il met fin à cette
politique
nous avons engrangé cette politique
s'est mérité aussi et nous avons arrêté
ces gaspillages et ceux qui ont des vies
alors il désormais nous allons mettre en
place c'est ce nouvelle politique
et oui quand la droite respecte ses
engagements quand la droite respecte ses
valeurs
quand la droite puisque et il dit ce
qu'elle fait et bien à ce moment là les
électeurs nous font confiance vous nous
faites confiance et c'est ce que nous
voulons encore renouvelé je citerai
vauban il n'y a aucune forteresse qui
est imprenable il n'y a que des
citadelles qui sont mal attaqué alors
nos maintenant les républicains qui
sommes unis qui sauvent déterminé alors
nous allons être en avant en avant pour
gagner
les régionales en 2015 en avant pour
gagner les présidentielles
et comme le disait nicolas sarkozy
l'alternance est en marche
rien ne pourra les arrêter bigné vous
shiren vie république vive la france
bravo les femmes